jack is in california hi jack welcome to
the ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve how can we help
um so i wanted some some advice on on my
current situation
um i started binge watching your show
about three weeks ago and
decided okay i'm gonna because i want to
buy a house soon so i
paid off all my credit cards um but the
problem i'm having right now is i have a
car that's
i spent way too much on last year and i
bought it brand new because
i drive about a hundred mile round trip
um so i spent 52
000 on my car um
and it's about 836 dollar payment
and i was thinking okay i'm just going
to go ahead and pay this off um
because the value has already decreased
to like 38 000 when i looked it up on
kelly blue book so what i wanted advice
on was
i have about 20 000 in my savings
good and i put my 401k on
on hold just last good um because i have
i had about 15 going in there i'm 25
years old i got 40k
in there which i want to use for a house
um
this year i'll make between 120 and 150.
excellent okay so and you the balance on
the car is what
the balance on the car is about 47 000
because i just bought it in september of
last year gotcha so you throw 20 at it
and that leaves us with 27
and you make 100 and some change and you
pay it off in a year right
yeah so that's what my my question was
because i was thinking of keeping
like 10 000 in my
yeah no it's ridiculous yeah it's
horrible
i'd be i'd be freaking out yeah
and i i realized uh you know watching
your show and then i started paying off
my credit card
and i was like you know what if i if i
want to buy a house i'm going to have a
mortgage payment and an 800
car payment now you're not doing
realistic i'll come i'll come to
california and box your ears you're not
doing that
no you you no you're too smart to do
that let me tell you where you're
struggling
okay you've learned all of this
information and
implemented all of this in a very short
period of time your intellect
went way ahead and left your emotions
behind
right you know what i'm saying like you
understood this intellectually and you
went
like ding ding ding ding ding and you
start doing it
and then you're kind of like getting a
little bit of emotional whiplash because
this has all happened in a relatively
short period of time agreed
yeah and and you know what watching your
show helps me out so much because
a lot of this stuff is the stuff that my
my parents are very frugal
um and they taught me all this stuff and
they were freaking out when you bought
this
52 000 car
yeah but they let they let me make my
mistakes well yeah
you're a grown man and that you know
stupid's not illegal and you explained
it to them in a good way why you needed
this one too
yeah 100 miles a week which means i'm
going to destroy the value faster
that was that was me justifying it in my
head yeah but i knew i heard you did
when i was doing it
yeah i heard you but you made me realize
uh how stupid it is when i started
watching your show
i think i think you're smart and i think
you're going to turn this around
it's just the re the reason you're
saying but but
we keep the ten thousand dollars is is
not because you intellectually don't
see how this is all going to pan out
it's because you've done it all in a
very short period of time and you went
from way over here in the land of stupid
to
rushing over into the land of the wise
and you got a little whiplash doing it
emotionally it takes your emotions a
little time to catch up
so give yourself permission to go this
feels weird but i'm going to do it
anyway
and you feel exposed when you get down
to that one thousand dollars and i think
that's the point right yeah we want you
running
well and we want all that money throwing
at this stupid car to get rid of this
debt
but when somebody binge watches dave
they realize oh gosh
i'm not safe and they immediately want
to get safe now yeah
and so it's i get that impulse i gotta
hang on to this and let me tell you the
other thing
those of you out there that are uh you
know you've been broke for
20 years live in paycheck to paycheck
and you work through this stuff and you
work your butt off and you're going to
sell intense for three years and then
you're debt-free and you don't have any
payments
and then you start actually getting some
money and then you look up and you go
dead gum i have several hundred thousand
dollars and i have no debt there's a
there's another thing that happens is
your emotions are still back there when
you were broke yeah and it feels weird
to be able to buy
a ten thousand dollar thing and just
write a check for it and it's not a big
deal
yeah mathematically intellectually but
your emotions are like
back there when you were broke right so
you got to heal along the way too yeah
i mean we spend more on copier paper and
coffee here
than i used to make right in this
building i mean
okay i have a thousand employees well i
looked down at that number and i said
your heart stops
numbers going through i'm like i'm that
little 28 year old guy that's back there
broke 30 years ago
i'm like crap yeah what a coffee
you know it's like oh it's a lot of
coffee so you know
the last time i bought a new car when i
was an idiot was was
a long time ago i went to we're looking
at buying my wife a a new car
or a used car new to her i thought
when did the prices go up and she was
like 25 years ago right but yeah it's
that same
they want what for a used car but as you
as you move away from
uh one set of financial values
and operating in one financial reality
and you move into another one
your intellect often goes before your
emotions almost always
and then like it's like later on so i
have to
look down at the coffee bill and go okay
this company did bring in 350 million
dollars so we can probably cover this
coffee bill
you know so shut up you little whining
boy
yes but on the other hand i look at that
number and it just there's still that it
still activates those old emotions
and so that tells me that still today my
emotions have not caught up with
the intellectual activities required to
run a 350
million dollar company and it may never
it may every time they do the company
grows so i can't keep up
that's right that's right i can't keep
the same thing with me you know sharon
and i were looking at buying something
last night and she goes i want to get
this
and i'm going to spend a lot of money
and she told me how much it was and i
went
that is not a lot of money you little
goop buy it but yeah
that nine-year-old little girl for me is
still like well that one
the one that was terrified and didn't
think we'd ever be able to fill up her
grocery basket again in the grocery
store
yeah and now can and not think about it
but she's like that's a lot of nanny
she's like a mischievous like she's
doing something wrong i'm like honey
puts two to zeroes on it and we'll call
it a lot of money that's not a lot
i think dave that is so wise that
whether it's your marriage whether it's
your kids
whether it's you're in a career money to
always just pause
have some built-in pauses to go
here's a conversation we were having
upstairs we're working on this new book
we know we say here if you're not
growing you're dying and i asked the
team it just hit me like a lightning
bolt
what does growing mean to you what does
growing mean to you and they were saying
you know intellectual stimulation
and exercise plan a good morning routine
and reading and spiritual growth and all
these things
and david occurred to me in this
conversation this is just yesterday by
the way so i'm still processing it but
when you go lift weights you're actually
tearing your muscles down
it's when you rest that the growth
happens and so it's both and
right it's it's crushing it and
reflection
and so it's gazelle intense and i'm in a
new stage here you are busting the
lactic acid man
yeah i'm in a new stage in a new stage
in a new stage
and there's the pruning that causes
growth yeah and man
it's always a breakdown to build up
always and when you it's when you read
that hard book or have that hard class
it's at night when you sleep that's when
the neurons grow that's when the growth
happens right
and so it goes back to it's both and
maybe i should sleep more
i'll always tell you that yes but
i love this gazelle and hey
don't forget to be reflective and
realize hey you're safe now you're safe
now
and now we're going to start working
about giving and building and it's it's
just
keep letting your make sure your head
and your heart stay connected through
this whole process man yeah that that's
um so jack all of that rant to say that
um for everybody else out there
listening what you're going through is
normal
yeah it's a it's a normal part of the
process for your emotions to catch up
with your intellect
take the whole 20 000 down to 1 000 work
the baby steps like you heard when you
were binging
and let's get that car paid off and get
that debt out of your life and the good
news is
you can look back when you're 54 and go
you know one of the dumbest things i
ever did was
back when i was 24. i bought a 50 000
car when i was 24. and you can look back
this could
you know you may have gotten the dumbest
thing out of the way i mean
we should have gotten the dumbest thing
already check that list
the dumbest thing you're ever going to
do could already be on the list
that's a win that's a good way to think
and
at the end of the day you end up with a
50 000 paid off card that's not a bad
not a bad way to end the consolation
prize this is the ramsay show